hey I'm Bobby Newport and I'm a regular
guy I like dogs
I'm here with my Persian Greyhound
Raclette who was given to me by my buddy
The Pretender to the crown of all sauce
Lauren how's it going I'm Bobby Newport
but you probably knew that already well
Mr Newport we made it last I'm Leslie
Knope ah okey-doke so do you want me to
sign that to miss lope or just nesney
what no I Leslie's fine Leslie yep Miss
nope is a candidate for city council
been calling your office trying to set
up a debate oh no you guys are robbed
I'm running on a pose I'm pretty sure
I'm running on a pose right
no you're not running unopposed you're
very opposed By Me Oh terrific I love
meeting people I love it yeah what do
you guys do
we we just told you we're going to be
running for city council great here have
a mommy bar go ahead my dad made him
okay folks hey I'm Bobby Newport I think
be scared of here have a Bobby bar my
dad made him I am Leslie Knope I love
this town and I've worked my whole life
to make it great
I believe that I've earned your vote
Bobby Newport believes he can buy it and
maybe that's because he's never earned
anything his entire life
that hurt my feelings I hurt my feelings
you're supposed to be this positive
person can we just talk about things we
like
well said uh just a reminder to our
candidates to keep it civil
looking at you Leslie ah it's okay Joan
I'm okay I'm just
I'm nervous man I'm nervous oh God I
guess I want to do a good job because
um I like it when people think I do a
good job and I want your vote because I
want Pawnee and my dad to see what I'm
made of
so let's do this
[Applause]
Wrecking Crew we let you guys in
hey Jason
hey Bobby
oh hi
want to play Boeing
why don't you play with the real one
oh I like this one better
little guy looks like me
hey can we talk for a second
look I just wanted to say I'm really
sorry your dad died and I'm really
really sorry I called him a jerk
that's okay
it was like a million years old
he was kind of a jerk
the only reason I did this campaign was
to impress him and he couldn't have
cared less
well my mom was a great athlete when she
was a kid
as a kid team to impress her
even though I hated it and at the end of
the year
I ran the 5 000 meters in this huge
Track event
and I
finished dead last
I thought she was going to be really
disappointed in me
but she wasn't she ran up to me and she
wrapped me up in this big hug and she
told me she had never been more proud of
me
thanks Leslie that's a great story
I'm not 100 sure I get the point you
finished this race Bobby
the campaign is over and you finished
win or lose
I'd bet you anything that your dad was
proud of you
now I get it there you go your mom and
my dad are both dicks
Mr Newport hello hi
Leslie Knope Ben Wyatt yeah I miss you
nice to see you you guys want anything
this is a restaurant so they have food
and stuff I'll take a milkshake oh we're
good
what can we do for you yes
um
why'd you guys post that video of me man
I mean that didn't make me feel good it
was it was mean you guys are mean
well we used your own ad so I I don't
think it was mean all right let me lay
it out for you my friends keep sending
me links to that video and they just
make fun of me it's just
okay just stop stop running the ad no
stop running the campaign
what just quit it would be so cool of
you if you just quit then I can win the
election and I'll have a big party and
I'll put you both on the guest list plus
one I'm gonna have a man who does magic
he's really good not like cheesy magic
like good magic We're Not Gonna
quit the campaign
why would we do that because
I want it come on give me it give me it
give me it come on give me it just give
me the election I'm sorry please
please well Leslie he does make a
compelling argument come on
guys Bobby oh it's not padded I'm Bobby
Newport
my family owns nine square miles of land
in this town and isn't my family what
this town's really about but Bobby
Newport the reason why Bobby and I are
appearing together is to send the
message that everyone should get out and
vote no matter who they're voting for
that's right another awesome Point by
Leslie that's why I'm voting for you
that's so funny you're laughing at your
joke not Joe I am voting for you
yourself
you camp over yourself I don't think
pretty sure that's illegal
this is my home
you are my family
and I promise you
I'm not going anywhere
holy let's see that was awesome
[Applause]
what is that
don't touch it I know this if something
is dirty we should clean it up let's
start there right
it's cleaning lady named Yolanda
who was very wise she basically raised
me and one day she said little Bobby I'm
not going to clean your room no moss and
from that day on my room was gross
really bummed me out I think we should
make our Parks look like my room after
Yolanda finally you know gave in and
cleaned it up for me I'm an American
my father is an American my mother is an
American
my godfather is the Viceroy of the
principality of Liechtenstein hi I'm
meat that I think that stinks that
happened to him you know one time a guy
stole some downhill skis out of my Jeep
and I was so mad I punched a mailbox I'm
against Crime and I'm not ashamed to
admit it
people keep asking me Bobby what are you
gonna do once you get in office
um
I'm pretty sure I'll figure it out
Bobby Newports never had a real job in
his life you got to give it more
attitude it's got to scare people Bobby
Newport yeah okay all right
Bobby Newports never had a real job in
his life Bobby Newports never had a real
job in his life Bobby newborn Bobby
Newport Bobby Newport Bobby Newport
Bobby Newport Newport
all right now we're just wasting time
Jerry
all right